le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
le prix célimène est un concours qui
célèbre la femme bien connue des
réunionnaises et réunionnais c'est un
événement en valorisant l'art est
reconnu comme un rendez vous culturel
local qui fête ses 11 années l'idée de
ce concours est de permettre une
exposition à des femmes artistes
amateurs souhaitant exprimer leurs
sentiments leurs idées leur vie ou leur
rêve par le texte la peinture la
sculpture ou la photo à qui s'adresse le
prix célimène on en parle tout de suite
dans lien social
le prix célimène est un concours réservé
aux femmes amatrice d'art et n'ayant
jamais exposé de façon professionnelle
une opportunité pour montrer où
confronté son talent ou son savoir faire
à des connaisseurs première vedette de
la réunion célimène surnommée la muse de
trois bassins a su séduire par ces vers
drôle et satirique au 19e siècle le prix
s'ils y mène est une initiative du
conseil général permettant aux femmes de
s'exprimer artistiquement
ce concours est l'occasion également de
célébrer la femme autrement que par des
journées de sensibilisation sur les
violences faites aux femmes ou des
violences intrafamiliales
emmanuel koenig passionné par la
photographie s'est inscrite au concours
célimène après un événement je continue
en machine attaquée aux événements
radiothérapie et j'avais du mal à voir
leurs regards seront les mêmes j'avais
besoin de faire quelque chose pour moi
il de retrouver mon estime je me suis
dit il faut que je participe à ce
concours ma passion oui la photo a
toujours été quelque chose que j'aime
bruit depuis mon adolescence et j'ai
toujours été fasciné par le fait qu'on
puisse capturer et certains événements
imprévisibles de et c'est pour moi un
moyen de communication
je trouve que parfois les photos sont
beaucoup plus parlant que les textes si
c'est une photo que j'ai pris en couleur
qui me plaît pas je préfère faire
ressortir l'émotion de la photo donc la
faire travailler donc je la mets en noir
et blanc car pour moi elle est beaucoup
plus expressive je fais pas de
de retouche personnel sur les
expressions du visage mais c'est surtout
voilà ce qui va entourer la photo pour
bien cibler pour bien ramener en fait ce
que je vais montrer sur la photo je veux
faire soit un recadrage
je fais un découpage ou alors une
amélioration trop de lumière
voilà mais je vais pas spécialement pour
toucher la photo parce que je veux
qu'elles gardent justement cette
authenticité pour exprimer ce qu'elle a
exprimé ce point et célimène en fait il
m'a apporté un autre regard sur moi même
il m'a permis de voir la vie autrement
aujourd'hui mes perspectives sont
d'avancé de prendre la vie comme elle
vient je vois que ça a apporté une
certaine fierté aussi auprès de mes
filles aujourd'hui je sais que je vais
capturé avec mon objectif chaque - qui
m'a permis de vivre au quotidien
géraldine gabin prolonge ses voyages en
peignant ses diverses rencontres
quand je peins j'explore des mondes qui
sont de plus en plus intérieure
imaginaire et dans seconde la gym et
beaucoup de ce que j'ai vu en voyageant
à travers le monde quand je parle je
congèle dessine j'explore les techniques
comme l'anc la gouache les collages les
stylos etc de manière autodidacte comme
je peux explorer le monde quand je
voyage je peins essentiellement des
portraits parce que ce que j'aime dans
la découverte du monde ce sont les
rencontres et notamment les regardant le
portrait sont très importants pour moi
parce que c'est par là que passent les
émotions et puis depuis peu je peins des
baobabs parce que le symbole me plaît
beaucoup c'est un arbre de vie de
fertilité et c'est un arbre très vivant
qu'on peut facilement personnifié et
donc de sebha au babc l'âge on fait des
personnages quand j'ai eu le premier
prix célimène en 2013 ça a d'abord été
un bel encouragement pour moi parce que
je me suis dit ça faisait que deux ans
que je paie ni à part ma mère et mes
amis qui n'est pas très objective on
m'avait jamais jamais eu de regard
extérieur par rapport à ce que je
faisais et donc bon encouragement parce
que des personnes d artistes d
professeur aux beaux-arts
m'ont dit ce jour-là ce que vous faites
ça a de l'intérêt et ça m'a engagé à
poursuivre et puis ça m'a apporté aussi
une certaine forme de reconnaissance et
de légitimité à poursuivre dans mon
travail et une légitimité à pouvoir
maintenant exposé ce que je fais je
dirais que c'est certes pas évident pour
la première fois de présenter son
intimité artistique et créative mais en
tout cas c'est ça apporte toujours
quelque chose très enrichissant et de
très constructif ce rassemblement de
femmes permet aussi de faire de très
belles rencontres c'est un concours qui
est très ouvert et qui nous libère un
petit peu de ce regard élitistes comme
en général les artistes et les lieux
d'expositions artistiques comme les
galeries d'art les musées etc et du coup
on se sent plus libre de s'exprimer dans
le cadre de son concours parce que
justement il est dédié aux amateurs et
il reconnaît que même si on est amateur
au départ on a une légitimité à
s'exprimer et s'exprimer à travers l'art
c'est toujours très intéressant à faire
et à recevoir
un moment unique et une perspective
incroyable pour celles qui souhaitent
continuer dans cette voie et pourquoi
pas de vivre de leur art l'art étant une
expression d'évasion le prix seligmann
est un rendez vous annuel de partage
d'amitié et de beauté pour être
candidate vous avez jusqu'au 11 février
inclus rendez vous sur le
www.cegedim.fr
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais